telecom giant Huawei Technologies has
long been at the center of drama between
the US and China but what exactly is
Huawei and why is the company so
significant here's what you need to know
first and foremost Huawei is a global
telecom behemoth it sold roughly 52
million smartphones in the last quarter
nearly seven million more than Apple it
employs 180,000 people more people than
Intel and it generated more than 92
billion dollars in revenue last year
that's more than twice that of Facebook
you might not use huawei products
because they aren't readily available in
the US and some other Western countries
regardless the company is the largest
maker of telecom equipment including
things like switches routers and cell
tower gear Huawei also sells personal
computers and a wide array of wireless
devices like smart watches and it's the
second largest smartphone company after
Samsung in China the company is seen as
the country's biggest global success
story so why is Huawei so important to
the u.s. it's all about competition not
only is the telecom giant a rival of
major Western companies but Huawei is
also seen as a global leader in 5g the
ultra-fast wireless technology that will
soon be connected to everything that's
good for China and bad for the US
Washington worries that if Huawei wins
the race to develop 5g technology
Americans could one day be forced to buy
equipment from the company and right now
no US companies are seen as major
competitors in this area the biggest
contenders are Sweden's Ericsson and
Finland Nokia but that's not all Huawei
is also seen as a cybersecurity threat
to the US Washington has accused the
company of being a potential conduit for
Chinese spying and cyber theft because
the company is so big and because it's
technology is used all over the world
the u.s. worries that Beijing could
force the company to engage in fair
activities like crippling communications
infrastructure remotely controlling or
destroying telecom gear or even spying
on America and its allies for its part
qua Way says its products are completely
safe and that the company does not do
any bidding for the Chinese government